Armstrong:
OVER THE PAST 2,000 YEARS,
THE PANTHEON HAS BEEN
A PAGAN TEMPLE, A CHURCH,
AND THEN A TOMB
FOR ITALIAN KINGS.
THE BUILDING WE SEE TODAY
WAS COMPLETED IN 126 A.D.
WHEN ROME RULED AN EMPIRE
THAT STRETCHED FROM
PORTUGAL TO PERSIA,
FROM SCOTLAND TO THE SAHARA.
[ WOMAN SINGING OPERA ]
I'M EXPLORING
THIS REMARKABLE BUILDING
WITH ARCHITECTURAL HISTORIAN
PROFESSOR ETTORE MAZZOLA.
THERE IS JUST SOMETHING
INCREDIBLE ABOUT IT,
ISN'T THERE?
-FANTASTIC.
THE INTERIOR IS A VAST CYLINDER,
BUT ITS CROWNING GLORY
IS THE DOME.
THIS IS STILL TODAY THE LARGEST
UNREINFORCED CONCRETE DOME
EVER BUILT ON THIS PLANET.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
A BUILDING
WHICH IS 43.3 METERS
IN DIAMETER.
I MEAN, THAT'S --
FOR US IN ENGLAND,
WE ALWAYS THINK OF ST. PAUL'S
WITH THIS AMAZING DOME,
BUT THIS DWARFS ST. PAUL'S.
THIS IS BIGGER,
AND IT'S POSSIBLE
ONLY BECAUSE OF THE MATERIAL
AND THE TECHNIQUE
USED TO BUILD IT.
WITHOUT STEEL TO REINFORCE
THE CONCRETE FROM WITHIN,
SURELY THIS DOME SHOULD COLLAPSE
UNDER ITS OWN WEIGHT.
SO, THEY DEVELOPED A SYSTEM
OF LOAD-BEARING ARCHES
THAT WERE CONCENTRATING
ALL THE FORCES
WITHIN THESE
EIGHT HUMONGOUS PILLARS.
AND YOU HAVE LOAD-SPREADING
ARCHES
THAT ARE CONCENTRATING
ALL THE FORCES
VERTICALLY INTO THE PILLARS.
BUT WHAT ALSO ENSURES
THESE WALLS CAN BEAR THE LOAD
WITHOUT BUTTRESSES IS THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE DOME ITSELF.
EACH OF ITS LAYERS IS MADE
WITH A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
MIX OF CONCRETE.
BASICALLY, THERE ARE SEVERAL
LAYERS OF DIFFERENT MATERIALS --
DIFFERENT MATERIALS
WITH DIFFERENT WEIGHT.
IN THIS MODEL, YOU CAN SEE HOW,
STEP BY STEP,
THE VAULT IS GROWING.
SO THE FIRST PART
IS MADE OF ROMAN CONCRETE
THAT HAS INSIDE FRAGMENTS OF
TRAVERTINE STONE AND TUFA STONE,
WHICH ARE HEAVY
AND VERY COMPACT.
AND STEP BY STEP, THESE
MATERIALS ARE GETTING LIGHTER,
AND THEN AT THE VERY END,
THERE IS ONLY THE PUMICE STONE
WHICH IS
CLOSING THE STRUCTURE.
SO THEY'RE CHANGING THE ACTUAL
MATERIAL THEY'RE USING
AS THEY GO UP, MAKING IT LIGHTER
AND LIGHTER AS THEY GO UP.
EXACTLY.
AND THEN AT THE VERY TOP,
THERE IS THIS BIG HOLE
WHICH IS 9 METERS IN DIAMETER,
WHICH IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
ALL THE FORCES, STEP BY STEP,
ARE GOING DOWN VERTICALLY
INTO THE PILLARS.
IT'S A CONSTANT PERFECT
BALANCE OF FORCES
THAT KEEPS THIS STRUCTURE
STANDING AS IT DOES.